yeah swords is going to come at you with
the four seam fastball a lot of
changeups curveball as well era just
over four he didn't start the season in
the rotation was out of the bullpen
leading off and what's different these
days is he's playing the outfield right
now
swinging a miss with the fastball away
and making quick work of tatis is jose
suarez
one down here in the first inning for
jake cronenworth
lined to third and reeled in by gosling
he was out before he got out of the box
there for jay cronenworth on a hot shot
two down
two down machado in scoring position at
second base after a battle with suarez
now to bring up tommy pham
fly ball headed out towards deep left
center field back is marsh it'll take
him to the dirt of the track but he
makes the catch that ends the enemy
there's the former first round draft
choice of
san diego padres towing the rubber for
the 17th time this year as a starter
lead runner on for the angels here in
the first inning brings up shohei ohtani
oh gosh and anna gets him on the
back of the handle with the wrist area
right wow yeah and i think you might be
right where the wrist area because he's
you know he's grabbing it a lot and you
figure if it got the pad
you know that's really over the back of
the hand
it is not going to be a hit batsman
situation because it was technically a
swing
as they checked with the third base
umpire jerry meals he said he went
around
so that was strike three so he may not
be coming out of this game just maybe
out and of course she is so he won't
know right away
that's a good sign yeah using that right
hand yeah you get the eye of navigating
and everything
at the plate is joe adele who's actually
hitting cleanup tonight for the angels
2-1 pitch and he straightens it out on a
line and diving is marisna to make the
catch
jake marisda
known for his defense in speed and we
just saw a little of both right there to
make the catch
one down in the second inning for jared
walsh
here's the next delivery this is lifted
high in the air this falls hit well out
to right field and it is out of here
that is a home run right there by jared
walsh
number 24 of the season
and the angels have the early
one-nothing lead
two on two down for manny machado
on the ground left side to short and
mayfield to go to second base for the
fourth south just in time
able to get a caller worth and to end
the innings so suarez pitches his way
out of the jam
so here's mayfield
he's hitting just
203. fly ball opposite field and deep
back is myers at the wall and that ball
is gone
two-run home run for jack mayfield his
eighth of the year
and the angels are out to a
three-nothing lead
second home run of the ball game for the
angels
yeah mayfield gets his fastball it's out
over the plate kind of up in the zone
and he just
drives this thing to right field johnny
back and staying in this game after
being hit
popped up this will have chronoworth
ducking back short stop to make the
catch in shallow left one and two on
hosmer fam leading at second
here's the pitch
and has reaches for it lines it out into
left center field that'll get down for a
base hit pam's rounding third on his way
home he'll score without a throw rbi
single eric osmer padres on the board
here in the fourth inning it's three to
one first and third nobody out of run
ends as austin nola stands in for the
padres
and nola lines one in the right field
for a base hit
hosmer from third will score myers is
headed to third so is to throw it he
will be
out at third base
so nola with the base hit that drives in
the second padres run but meyers trying
to go first to third is thrown out
there's a scoring position hitting it
366 and he's got two on here
with two outs tati's hit step that's
hard
it's this hard to center field but it's
caught building a cap high by brandon
marsh is jared walsh for the second time
in this game he bats with the runner at
first base
drives this towards the gap in right
center field and that's going to get
down tatis back to play it heading for
third is adele they're going to try to
wave him around and score all the way
from first throw to the plate will be
late
and the angels take a 4-2 lead
that wild pitch will easily move walsh
over to third base
open here's a drive out to left field
where maurizio goes over and so does
tati san fernando make the catch dang it
third is walsh here comes the throw
it'll be late
and the angels get their fifth run of
the ball game and their three-run lead
back again it's five to two
owen one to count see if shohei's gonna
be on the move here shohei again 19
stolen bases
there he goes and he's on the move the
pitch was a ball the throw bounces in
and that's an easy stolen base
so otani gets his 20th of the season the
first player in angels history the 40-20
guy in his season the angels have a pair
of runners on
to right field and that's going to get
in for a base hit coming out from second
is ohtani he will score
stopping at third is gosling on the rbi
double by adele
and the angels up their lead to six to
two pieces loaded for the angels one out
of the inning and a 2-2 pitched up and
again
fly ball headed out to right center
field fernando calling for it and tatis
will make the catch tag at third base is
gosling the throw to the play to be late
and the angels had on on top seven two
sac fly for justin upton
well congratulations to mr upton there 1
000 rbis
pieces are loaded here for the angels
one out in the inning phil gosling
gosling will set it up the middle and by
the dive of chronoworth scoring his
mayfield fletcher behind him two more
runs in for the angels who take a 9-2
lead
[Applause]
to washington
up the middle and into center field
around from second comes ohtani he will
score
make it 10-2 angels on top
is into the game the closure for the
angels in a 10-2 game just getting some
work here sj chronoworth leads it off
here in the ninth inning
popped up shallow left incoming is adele
and he'll make the catch for the first
out of the night
one out in the ninth and that'll bring
up hassan kim
even kim here
strike three two down in the ninth
inning
swing and a miss and carratini strikes
out to end the ball game